hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd tutorial and in this video i'll be
going over a web browser you may or may
not have heard of brand new for windows
called slim browser
so slim browser as you heard me say
before is a brand new web browser for
windows that really allows for a very
light and as you can tell by the name a
very slim web browsing experience now it
does happen to be based off of internet
explorer so i'm going to give you guys a
basic rundown of this internet browser
first of all you can get this at the
link in the description it is build 0.3
of version 4.12 and it has gotten a lot
of positive reviews from cnet.com so i'm
definitely gonna be showing this to you
guys and like i said the link that you
can get this at to download right now is
in the description so anyway i'm going
to open up the browser itself here this
is the shortcut on my desktop if i just
go ahead and double click it you'll see
the speed at which it opens up
first pretty much for a cold boot is the
slowest boot then once we maximize you
can tell
it's going to have to be pretty much a
whole boot is going to be the slowest
boot then every time from then on out
it's going to be pretty quick but that's
the first time i've booted this browser
today
so if we just go ahead and take a tour
around it here you'll notice it is
definitely based off of internet
explorer like i said however internet
explorer as we all know is a pretty bad
web browser however if we just go ahead
and uh test a few page loads here
such as youtube.com and i'm actually
signed in because of the auto remember
that i've selected it does open really
really quickly so i just go ahead and i
go to my subscriptions which actually
does tend to take a while it's pretty
quick and it works very quickly now if i
go back up here to the top you have a
toolbar called my search this is a
toolbar that is built into the browser
and as we can go down here we can search
uh different categories of things so we
can search our built-in calendar we can
search uh news movies sports tv weather
etc so if i search tv it'll
automatically redirect me to the
built-in my search tv searching website
so it's a very very uh it's a fully
functional browser in the first place
and it does seem like a watered-down
version of something like firefox or
internet explorer but it does have a lot
of features built in that you normally
wouldn't expect so back to the youtube
tab you'll also notice you can right
click on it on a tab in this second
column here and you'll have a number of
options for things that you can do with
this tab you can close it
or you can right click on a tab and
duplicate it which is basically opening
the exact same tab twice
you can also right click on one and hide
it lock it
to prevent it from closing you can add
it to a group and are basically a
favorite you can close all tabs or you
can close all but current tab which is
actually one of my favorite features
also you can add this into white list
into blacklist and a number of other
things that you would really have to get
to use this browser for a while to know
the name of and also there's a built-in
auto refresh feature
now if we look up here on the right hand
side of the browser where the minimum
maximum and x buttons usually are you
will see some very similar looking
buttons that actually perform the same
tasks with a different look this is the
minimize button this is the maximize
button and this is the exit out button
so if i press this button right here
it'll minimize
and exactly uh this is the restore
button as you could say to bring it down
to a window and to resize the window so
it does have very very similar features
with internet explorer
so the last really unique feature about
this web page is the toolbar up here at
the other side the top left hand corner
so if we go ahead and hit the file
button file edit and view are really
very standard features that you'll
probably also see in any other web
browser favorites are slightly different
in this web browser but not really
notable if we go to language this is
something that's actually quite
convenient if you happen to be on a
spanish or a different a french website
and you speak english you can hit
control t and the built-in web browser
add-on will just go ahead and translate
that page into english for you you can
also use babelfish translation or google
translation i think that's a very
convenient feature and it's nice that
they built that in next is groups it's
very similar to favorites however you
have a different method of organizing
your groups you can save different
groups and different types of groups and
basically it's a very very efficient way
of organizing your bookmarks also auto
login is directly in the toolbar as well
so you can control different ways that
you auto log into pages as you saw
before i auto logged into google and
youtube and they work flawlessly tools
is in any other youtube or any other web
browser as you can see you can set this
as your default browser you can now use
your uh email settings or your so your
filters and set all these different
internet options and as well as your
auto fill options as well in tools
last but not least there are windows and
help which are also quite normal options
for any other web browser so as you guys
can see it's a very clean very quick web
browser it's going to import your
bookmarks directly from internet
explorer so if you have any saved like i
said they'll definitely be killer
loading times and you'll pretty much
have uh the off the optimal web browser
uh for your pc if you're looking for
something lightweight so this has been
marcus brownlee from mkbhd and thank you
for watching this tutorial on flash peak
slim browser i hope you enjoyed and
maybe you'll be inspired to check out
the browser yourself and uh that has
basically been it so thank you for
watching this tutorial and i'll catch
you guys in the next video peace